Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachname?
Bene, du musst es nur sagen.
Entschuldigung, ich habe ein Problem gehabt.
Okay.
Jetzt hören.
Alles gut.
Okay, können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname langsam bestabieren?
A wie Anton, D wie Dora, A wie Anton, M wie Marta, S wie Fried.
Okay.
Wie alt sind Sie?
65 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1957, 1.3.
1. am März.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 65.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg.
Okay.
Herr Adams, was fühlt Sie denn zu uns?
Mein Hausarzt hat mich zu ihm geschickt.
Ich sollte mich hier vorstellen.
Was für Beschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe Luftnot gehabt.
Er hat eine EKG gemacht.
Er sagte, ich soll hierhin kommen.
EKG war auffällig, oder?
Hat er gesagt, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihre EKG dabei?
Oder wissen Sie, was ist los?
Nein, er sagte, ich soll direkt hierhin kommen.
Ach so, okay.
Ich bleibe aber nicht hier, ich gehe wieder nach Hause.
Ich werde nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben, ich möchte direkt wieder nach Hause.
Ich habe mich gezeigt.
Ein bisschen geduht, brauchen Sie?
Okay, es könnte ein bisschen...
Ich habe ein bisschen geduht.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Wir brauchen hier nur eine Stunde,
denke ich, für diese Untersuchung.
Aber wenn Sie unbedingt nach Hause gehen wollen,
Sie können gegen Asli Herr Rad nach Hause gehen.
Ja, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit mir?
Ich meine, mir geht es auch gut soweit.
Gehen Sie mir eine Tabette und ich gehe nach Hause.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Luftnot haben.
Wir wissen noch nicht, warum haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Ja, wir brauchen hier nur eine Stunde,
denke ich, für diese Untersuchung.
Ich habe nicht viel Zeit.
Das haben Sie diese Beschwerde.
Wir können Sie nicht direkt behandeln.
Das müssen wir erst mal diagnostizieren.
Dafür brauchen Sie ein bisschen geduht zu haben.
Aber wenn Sie nicht wollen,
dann können Sie nach Hause gehen.
Aber das könnte gefährlich sein.
Wenn Ihre EKG auffällig ist,
das muss ich Ihnen auch erklären.
Sie müssen ein Papier unterscheiden.
Ja, das ist so.
Was ist Ihre Frage?
Das ist Ihre Entscheidung.
Ja, dann machen wir das.
Ich habe mich viel Zeit.
Okay, geben wir dann weiter.
Alles gut?
Ja, alles gut.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Luftnot?
Ich habe das immer wieder.
Ich habe das schon seit mehreren Monaten, glaube ich.
Wenn ich im Garten arbeite,
dann merke ich das besonders.
Ich habe das schon seit mehreren Monaten, glaube ich.
Wenn ich im Garten arbeite,
dann merke ich das besonders.
Sie meinen beim Belastung?
Beim Schäpensteigen haben Sie auch?
Ja, das auch.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt,
dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay.
Seit mehreren Monaten haben Sie,
Sie haben immer diese Luftnot.
Wenn Sie sich belasten,
dann merken Sie,
dass Ihre Beine geschwollen sind.
Sie haben immer diese Luftnot.
Wenn Sie sich belasten.
Ja, wenn ich im Garten arbeite,
oder wie Sie gesagt haben,
wenn ich Treppen steige,
dann muss ich ein bisschen Pause machen
und dann habe ich so Herzrasen.
Alles gut.
Herzrasen, okay.
Haben Sie auch Brustschmerzen?
Du könntest das Gefühl auf der Brust?
Nein, habe ich gar keine Schmerzen.
Mir geht es sonst wunderbar.
Sie haben Herzrasen gesagt,
habe ich richtig verstanden?
Ja, ich habe meinen Herzköpfen.
Das merke ich schon.
Okay.
Wie lange dort, wenn Sie Herzrasen haben?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich mache dann Pause
fünf Minuten, dann wird es wieder besser
und dann kann ich weitermachen.
Ach so, ja.
Okay, Sie haben aber keine Schmerzen.
Gar nicht, gar nicht.
Mir geht es sonst wunderbar.
Wunderbar.
Gusten Sie? Nein.
Sie haben auch keine Ausrufe.
Nein.
Haben Sie mehr oder mehr,
dass Sie Fieber haben?
Ich fühle mich überhaupt nicht krank.
Okay.
Deswegen bleibe ich auch nicht im Krankenhaus.
Ach so, ja.
Das sind 65 Jahre alt, oder?
Genau.
Warum waren Sie beim Hausarzt?
Also meine Frau
ist an Brustkrebs verstorben.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Und ich habe immer wieder diese Luft.
Deswegen habe ich Angst gehabt
und wollte mich mal beim Arzt vorstellen.
Ja, das verstehe ich.
Sie haben, ich denke,
gut, sehr gut gemacht.
Okay.
Ich glaube, Sie müssten nur ein Renten machen
und dann kann ich wieder nach Hause gehen.
Ich möchte auch gerne ein EKG scheiden,
weil Sie Ihre EKG-Befinde nicht dabei haben.
Wir wissen noch nicht,
warum Sie vom Hausarzt hier überwiesen haben.
Ich glaube, Sie müssen das nicht mehr machen.
Aber wir wissen noch nicht,
warum Sie vom Hausarzt hier überwiesen haben.
Ich versuche,
alles schnell zu machen.
Aber ja,
es ist eine wichtige Situation.
Das müssen wir eigentlich
erklären.
Gut, dann machen wir das.
Okay.
Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie keine Fieber haben.
Keine
Brustschmerzen, kein Husten.
Okay.
Wie fühlen Sie sich denn sonst körperlich?
Ganz gut.
Ganz gut eigentlich.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nur manchmal diese Luftnoten,
Herzrasen.
Ansonsten fühle ich mich wunderbar.
Ja, außer Luftnoten
oder und Herzhasen
haben Sie etwas
ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Nein.
Ja, wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Seite
an Gewicht verloren?
Nein.
Im Gegensatz, ich habe zugenommen.
Wie viel Kilo haben Sie zugemäßen?
Hab ich nicht gemessen, aber
ich habe mich vor 300 gewogen.
Da habe ich 80 Kilo gewogen.
Okay.
Mach das nicht so oft.
Sind 1,65 Meter
Vorsorge?
Ja.
Das ist eigentlich ein bisschen viel.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme
beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Ich habe keine Beschwerden, gar nichts.
Können Sie denn flach liegen, ohne Atemot zu bekommen?
Ich schlafe gut.
Gut.
Brauchen Sie ein paar Kisten
zu benutzen?
Nein.
Nein, keine.
Ich habe ein Kissen, eine Decke, ein Backs.
Ich fülle mich aus.
Spüren Sie
Herzklopfen?
Jetzt aktuell nicht.
Nein, aktuell nicht.
Nach der Besprechung
möchte ich Ihnen eine EKG schreiben.
Haben Sie Probleme
beim
Einschlafen?
Sie haben gesagt, nein.
Ja, ich habe
genau.
gibt es dann in ihrer Krankengeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte, Rhythmusstörung, Bluthochdruck.
Ja, ich nehme ein Blutdruck Medikamente ein.
Ein Blutdruck Medikamente ein.
Okay, Sie haben Bluthoch.
Ich morgens immer.
Und ich nehme auch abends aus dem Schlafen ein.
Okay, was nehmen Sie gegen Bluthochdruck, wissen Sie?
Ramipril.
Ja, wie viel Milligramm?
Ich glaube, das war 50 oder 5, ich weiß es nicht, irgendwie sowas.
5 Milligramm, okay.
Einmal morgens.
Genau.
Und abends, was nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme etwas um den Schlafen ein, damit ich ruhig schlafen kann.
Schlafen.
Das nehme ich aber schon lange ein.
Aber wissen Sie die Namen nicht, oder?
Das ist Mirtha Zappin.
Mirtha Zappin, okay.
Und wie viel Milligramm?
Weiß ich nicht, ich glaube 10 oder 15 weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Bei Ihnen eine Bluthochdruckbeckante, außer dieser haben Sie
irgendeine Erkrankung?
Nicht das Würste.
Okay, würden Sie dann schon mal operiert?
Als Kind, mein Blinddamm ist raus.
Wie alt waren Sie?
50 Jahre her bestimmt.
War kurz nach dem Krieg.
Wie bitte?
Es war kurz nach dem Krieg.
Es war kurz nach dem Krieg, als ich operiert wurde.
Alles klar.
Nein, das ist vor 50 Jahren.
Vor 50 Jahren?
Ja.
Aber ich bin 15 Jahre alt.
15 Lebensjahr, 15 in Lebensjahr.
Genau, richtig.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen allergienbeckante?
Nein.
Keine Unverzwecklichkeit gegen Laktose?
Ich kann alles essen.
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Sie haben ein Laktose gegen?
Ich kann alles essen.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sind Sie regelmäßig geimpft, auch gegen Corona?
Ja, ich habe jetzt drei Impfungen bekommen.
Das ist gut.
Ich mache aber nicht.
Natürlich nicht.
Ich habe im Fernsehen gesehen, dass das nicht bringt.
Immer wieder stecken, ja.
Im Fernsehen sagen wir, das bringt gar nichts.
Aber ich lasse mich nicht impfen.
Und ich auch nicht.
Lassen Sie, dass Ihre Idee,
ich kann das verstehen,
aber lassen Sie uns erst mal
aktuelle Situation konsentieren.
Was ist damit der Impfung zu tun?
Gar nichts, oder?
Mit welchen?
Das hat doch nichts mit dem Impfung zu tun,
oder?
Diese Luftnot.
Ich denke, nein.
Aber wann war Ihre letzte Impfung?
schon in Dezember gewesen.
Schon Dezember? Ja, nicht echt, denke nein.
Gut. Ich hätte mich auch nicht impfen lassen sollen.
Bring alles nichts.
Okay, Herr Erdem, ich möchte nach Ihrer Lebensgewohnheiten fragen.
Zum Beispiel rauchen Sie, schinken Sie Alkohol, eventuell auch Durgen.
Also ich habe aufgehört mit dem Rauchen vor fünf Jahren, als meine Frau gestorben ist.
Ja, alles klar.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Auch mit 15 habe ich angefangen, glaube ich.
Ach so, dann 45 Jahre.
Und wie viel Seguratte haben Sie geraucht pro Tag?
Ein weniger, mein viel. Kommt immer drauf an.
Ich habe auf der Baustelle gearbeitet, habe man schon oft geraucht.
Was könnte das durchschnittlich sein, vielleicht ein Packkuchen?
Ja, bestimmt. Locker.
Okay, und schinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich denke immer abends Bier.
Okay, jeden Tag, oder?
Jeden Tag, immer abends vom Schlafen gehen.
Wenn ich es trage, schaffe ich immer Bier.
Ein Flasche oder mehr als ein Flasche?
Kommt aufwand, wenn ein guter Film ist, dann trinke ich auch mal zwei Bier oder drei Bier.
So nachdem ich fühle.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie schon mal Durgen probiert?
Nein, nein.
Okay, das ist gut.
Gibt es in Ihrer Nachhineinverwandtschaft wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Weiß ich nicht.
Meine Eltern sind früh gestorben, die sind mit 40 und 45 gestorben.
Mit anderen anderen habe ich gar keinen Kontakt.
Okay, Sie haben keinen Kontakt.
Wissen Sie, woran ist Ihre Mutter und Vater gestorben?
Damals gab es Infektionserkrankungen, glaube ich, und Mama weiß ich nicht.
Sie ist auch plötzlich verstorben.
Plötzlich?
Ja, ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Herr Adams, was machen Sie vom Beruf?
Sie haben gesagt, ich habe das nicht verstanden.
Sind Sie Rentner?
Ich bin Rentner, aber ich habe immer auf der Baustelle gearbeitet.
Ganz lange.
Okay, sind Sie?
Sie sind Lady, oder?
Ich bin verwitzelt, meine Frau ist gestorben.
Sie sind eine Frau, oder?
Sie wohnen alleine, oder?
Ich wohne alleine mit meinen Tieren.
Ich habe Hunde und Katzen, die reichen mir raus.
Ja, ich habe auch eine Katze.
Ein Katze reicht aus.
Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Herr Adams, haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, ich möchte nach Hause.
Wie lange dauert das Ihnen jetzt noch?
Was machen Sie mit mir?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Sie eine Rhythmusstörung haben.
Um eine genaue Aussage machen zu können,
möchte ich bei Ihnen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich möchte Sie körperlich untersuchen,
Ihre Lunge und Ihre Herzabhörung.
Das habt auch schon mein Hausarzt gemacht, aber ich darf keine Zeit führen.
Ich habe keine Befunde dabei, das bedeutet uns leider nichts.
Das kann man noch einmal machen.
Leider, ja.
Es dauert aber ein paar Minuten.
Ja, dann los.
Und dann, was passiert dann?
Ich nehme bei Ihnen Blut ab.
Ich möchte ein Röntgen unternehmen.
Wie lange dauert das, bis das Ergebnis kommt vom Blut?
Ich denke, zwei Stunden.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Stunde dauert das.
Unsere Prosedere dauert eine Stunde,
aber nach dieser, Sie müssen auf das Ergebnis erwarten.
Meine Tiere zu Hause, ich muss sie nicht zu Hause lassen.
Die können ein paar Tage ohne sie bleiben.
Nein, wie paar Tage.
Ich bleibe nicht hier.
Ich fahre wieder nach Hause gleich.
Okay.
Wie gesagt, wenn Sie unbedingt nach Hause wollen,
dann Sie können gegen Asli Herr Rath,
Krankenhaus verlassen, aber ich schlage vor,
hier diese Prosedere zum Ende zu führen.
Damit wir wissen, warum haben Sie dieser Beschwerden?
Ich habe es mir schon gesagt,
warum haben Sie dieser Beschwerden?
Wir können auch das behandeln.
Ich habe es mir schon gesagt,
geben Sie ein Medikament und dann bin ich wieder weg.
Wenn Sie eine Rhythmusstörung haben und keine Medikamente haben,
das könnte zum Beispiel Schlaganfahrführung.
Das ist eine wichtige Situation.
Deswegen müssen wir erst mal die Untersuchung zu Ende führen.
Es geht um Ihre Gesundheit eigentlich.
Was machen Sie da jetzt?
Wenn Sie nicht hier bleiben wollen, dann ist Ihre Entscheidung.
Ich will nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Ich habe bestimmt nichts.
Machen Sie ein Röntgenbild von meiner Lunge.
Wenn ich keinen Krebs habe, ist alles gut.
Das läuft nicht so.
Wenn Sie wollen, Untersuchung zu lassen, dann ...
Was machen Sie denn anders als mein Hausarzt?
Er hat doch schon EKG gemacht.
Traum? Wie bitte?
Was machen Sie denn jetzt anders als mein Hausarzt?
Er hat doch schon EKG gemacht.
Aber keine Medikamente gegeben, oder?
Nein, er hat gesagt, ich soll ins Krankenhaus.
Ich habe nicht zu Ihrer Hausarzt-Fragen.
Das kann ich nicht antworten.
Jetzt bin ich schon mal hier.
Wir machen dann vom Anfang bis zum Ende.
Ich habe Hunger. Ich habe noch nichts gegessen heute.
Ich habe auch Hunger.
Dann essen Sie etwas. Aber ich muss nach Hause.
Ich kann nicht essen, leider.
Ich habe noch nichts gegessen.
Was passiert jetzt?
Jetzt möchte ich mit meiner Arzt sprechen.
Dann komme ich zu Ihnen.
Sind Sie kein Oberarzt?
Nein, ich bin die Assistenzarztin.
Das ist so.
Wenn Sie mit Chefarzt sprechen wollen,
dann machen Sie ein Pirouatversichung.
Dann können Sie das machen.
Tschüss.
Was habe ich denn jetzt überhaupt?
Ich spreche noch mit Patienten.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre EKG unauffällig war.
Das war auffällig.
Ja, ich denke, Sie haben eine Rhythmus gestorgen.
Sie haben Herz plopfen.
Sie haben eine Rhythmus gestorgen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass Sie Probleme mit Ihrem Herzen haben.
Aber um genauer Aussage machen zu können,
möchte ich die alle untersuchen.
Ich mache bei einem Blutabnehmen,
um zu gucken, ob mit dem Blut alles in Ordnung ist.
Sie haben Luft.
Ich habe aber ein bisschen übergewischt.
Ja, 80 kg.
Ja.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Alles gut.
Guten Tag, Herr Auberarzt.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ich habe eine neue Aufnahme.
Ich berichte über Herr Frank Adams.
Er ist 65 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,65 m groß und wiegt seit 80 kg.
Der Patient stellte sich wegen der Belastungsdispine.
Er war heute bei einem Hausarzt.
Er war beim Hausarzt.
Dabei wurde eine EKG durchgeführt.
Das war auffällig.
Aber der Patient hatte keine Briefe und keine EKG.
Er befand dabei.
Dieser Blutnot habe er seit mehreren Monaten.
Beim Belastung, z.B. beim Schäpensteigen.
Er hatte Brustschmerzen.
Er hatte Neukom友.
Er hatte einen Brustschmerzen.
Er hatte eine evil Lbies-,
Oder ein BC5 3-Beeber.
Er hatte glowing eyes.
Die Vegetative an Amnesie sei unauffällig. Die Frage nach
Verkrankung er gab Atelierlechipthatonie. Seit wieviel
Jahren habe ich vergessen zu fragen. Dagegen nehmen er
Romyprilf-5-Miligramm einmal morgens ein. Bei ihm würde
eine Pandektomie mit fünf Centenlebensjahr durchgeführt.
Bei ihm sei keine Allergien bekannt. Im Stativ sei
vollständig die Noxen-Anamnese er gab. Er sei
Exraucher mit 45 Paketjahre vor fünf Jahren. Er sei seine
Frau gestorben und hat er dann mit dem Silvert abgesetzt.
Alkoholkonsum wurde mit einem bis drei Flaschen täglich bejaht.
Er habe keine Drogenkontakt. Bei der Familienanamnese
er gab Vaterliches. Also ich habe leider keine
Informationen über diese Anamnistik. Der Patient habe
keine Kontakt mit seiner Familie. Er gab an, dass
seiner Vater an einer Infektion seine Mutter plötzlich gestorben. Er sei
Rentner. Er habe als Baustelle gearbeitet. Er
sei verwirrt. Er habe keine Kinder und lebe alleine mit
seiner Tiere zusammen. Aufgrund der
Anamnistischen-Agengaben gehe ich verdacht auf
eine Vorhoffliman aus. Dafür sprechen die
also EKG-Auffälligkeiten. Ich denke, eine
Rhythmusstorgen oder Erregungsbildungsstorgen. Aber er
habe auch eine Atemot bei Belastung.
Der Fernseher diagnostisch kommen Koronare, Herzkrankheit,
heißen Sufisien, Klappenviten, Infrage,
zu weiterer Abkühlung führe ich eine, möchte ich die
patienten Körperlich untersuchen, die Lunge abholen
und sogar Knob-Lunge-Deme gibt oder nicht. Herz abhören. Ich
möchte auch bei ihm Blutdruck messen. Also bei ihm war
er eine Atelierleipatone, die bekannt
habe ich, um kontrollierte
Atelierleipatonie. Ich potenzielle Entgleisung,
oder ja, der Fernseher diagnostisch, ja,
ich potenzielle Entgleisung. Okay, das ist alles.
Okay, machen Sie auch ein Röntgenbild? Ja. Warum machen Sie
ein Röntgenbild? Um zu schauen,
ob es auch eine Stauungszeichen gibt oder nicht?
Also ich denke keine Pynomonie, aber
eine Stauungspinomonie kann sein, ja. Ich möchte
jedenfalls eine Röntgen-Torax antworten.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie LKG gemacht und Sie haben
gesehen, der Patient hat Vorfliehmann.
Und deine Herzbequenz 135. Was machen Sie?
135. 135. Ach so, ja.
Was machen Sie? Der Blutdruck ist bei 110 zu 80.
Was machen Sie mit dem Patienten?
Ich möchte erst mal mit der
Verkaufung von Korrelationen anfangen.
Ich möchte also inoxeperin
spitze. Okay.
Und ich mache
für Stabilisierung
mit Abpremier-Meter-Betropyl-Kor-Geben.
Metapolol zum Beispiel. Okay.
Machen Sie das als Tabletze oder geben Sie das
IV oder so Couchon oder wie machen Sie das?
Ich gebe IV.
IV. Ja.
Was müssen Sie dabei beachten, wenn Sie das IV geben?
Also es könnte zu allergischer Reaktion führen, oder?
Ja. Also sollten Sie mit dem Patienten
vorher machen, bevor Sie IV Medikamente geben.
Ja, das ist das.
Okay, also.
Aber Sie müssen Ihnen an ein Monitor anschließen, ne?
Sie müssen Ihnen beobachten, wenn Sie IV Medikamente geben.
Ach so, okay.
Okay.
Dann sollten Sie Ihnen ein Monitor dran machen
und dabei das IV Medikament geben.
Okay.
Ja, das würde ich so machen. Okay.
Ich würde eine Esch-Untersuchung
anfordern.
Freitag.
Freitag? Es ist Freitag.
Es ist 16.30 Uhr.
Auf dem Weg nach Hause als Oberarzt.
Ach so.
Ja, das ist Freitag, Nachmittag 16.30 Uhr.
Ich würde es, also,
wenn die Patienten Symptome hat,
auch in der Ruhe haben,
müssen wir mit dem Therapie beginnen,
eigentlich für Proflaxie einmal
und für Rhythmus-Controller.
Haben Sie gesagt, Sie geben Wetterblocker
und Sie geben Clexan, also Einungsapparien geben Sie?
Ja, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir
Indikation haben für stationäre Aufnahme.
Aber ich denke, ja.
Möchtet der Patient entbleiben?
Nein.
Er möchte unbedingt nach Hause gehen.
Okay.
Würden Sie ihn denn nach Hause lassen, oder nicht?
Nein.
Warum nicht?
Was ist der Grund, dass Sie ihn heute da lassen?
Wie bitte?
Was ist der Grund,
warum Sie den Patienten heute am Freitag,
Nachmittag aufnehmen möchten?
Weil wir Komplikationsrisiken haben
bei...
Ataschaulit, mir absoluto.
Und es könnte auch aufgrund einer
Herzerkrankung sein. Er habe viele Risikofaktoren.
Er hat Gelbertonie, Adiposität, Nekotinobusis.
Okay.
Was passiert denn am Wochenende?
Im Krankenhaus? Was machen Sie am Wochenende im Krankenhaus?
Mit dem Patienten?
Also eigentlich, ich würde...
ich könnte die Patienten auftreten, damit sie anschließen,
damit ich der Patient überwachen könnte.
Ich wollte da...
da er keine Therapie hat, noch keine Therapie hat,
der Patient noch nicht zu Hause schicken.
Ich möchte auch für weitere Prozedere.
Also Sie würden am Wochenende
erstmal Rhythmuskontrolle machen
und eine orale Anticoagulation einleiten.
Ja.
Und am Montag eigentlich die Diagnostik beginnen.
Ich konnte eigentlich direkt
Freitag an...
vielleicht...
wir brauchen das nicht, aber wir können...
Langsider AKG und Langsider Nudetruppmessung antworten.
Ja, es ist schon belegt. Es ist nichts mehr frei.
Wir sind auch belegt?
Freitag ist alles belegt.
Also Sie können den Patienten nur aufnehmen.
Und wie Sie gesagt haben, Sie können den entweder an die
Telemetrie anschließen. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wir haben das aber nicht. Die haben nur Intensivstation
und Chest Pain Unit zum Beispiel
oder eine Intimidate Care Unit
und da kann man ihn an einem Monitor überwachen.
Okay, der Patient
möchte aber nicht da bleiben
und er möchte nach Hause unbedingt.
Was machen Sie?
Ich möchte erstmal aufklären,
warum der Patient
im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Ich würde mal erklären,
die Risiken...
Das ist ja nicht seit gestern.
Er hat das schon seit Monaten.
Aber wir haben das festgestellt
und müssen wieder mit dem Therapie anfangen.
Dass es mit dem Patienten noch keinen Schlaganfahr hat,
ist besser.
Frau Gündo, Sie haben angefangen, Sie haben ihm
eine Exoparie gegeben und Sie haben ihm
eine Metaprololi-V gegeben.
Sie haben gesehen, am Monitor, die Herz-Rückwärts ist bei 110.
Dann kann ich die Patientin nach Hause schicken
und eine Elektivarteile geben.
Mit welchem Medikament geben Sie?
Mit Norrk.
Mit Peter.
Und was sagen Sie dem Patienten?
Ich sage dem Patienten...
Ich würde dem Patienten einen Beef geben
mit dieser Medikamente.
Medikamente so anscheinend lassen.
Ja, danach ich würde eine
elektrive Termin für
weitere Untersuchungen wie zum Beispiel
ESHO, vielleicht Herzgedäte-Untersuchungen,
ein Termin planen.
Womit fangen Sie?
Ja, Sie bestellen ihn elektrisch ein.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Und welche Untersuchungen werden dann gemacht?
Sie haben ESHO gesagt.
Wenn der Blutdruck nicht gut eingestellt ist,
dann vielleicht Langzeit-HKG.
ESHO habe ich gesagt.
Wir können, wenn er noch...
Wie machen wir ein normales ESHO?
Also, ja, wenn ich eine Therapie denke,
zum Beispiel Elektro-Cardiobation,
dann muss ich eine Chance, unser Fregial-Escho machen
und zu ausschließen, irgendein Fische-Tombus.
Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie wollen ihn therapieren.
Dann müssten Sie eigentlich direkt an eine Elektro-Cardiobation denken.
Es ist doch die Therapie.
Wenn ich gerade sie... ja, wenn ich gerne...
Aber vielleicht eine Blockgabe,
vielleicht, dass er Proxys-Mahl hat, aber ja.
Wenn aber nachdem ich stationär aufnahme,
kann ich mit dieser Verfahren anfangen.
Elektro-Cardiobation.de.
Das können Sie als elektrisch machen.
Sie können sagen, wir nehmen Sie stationär auf am Montag oder am Dienstag
und wir machen ein normales ESHO und dann machen wir einen Langzeit-Cardiobation.
Aber die machen wir auch beide Aufnahmen,
beide stationär aufnahmen, oder?
Genau, Sie nehmen die elektrisch-stationär auf.
Ja. Ja.
Und dann müssten Sie aber auf jeden Fall eine
trans-esophageale ESHO-Cardiobau-Fee machen, ne?
Ja.
Warum müssten Sie das machen?
Also im Herz
Vorhof, auch die Kulade Herzhof bildet sich Trombose bei Vorhof-Limmern.
Genau, richtig.
Das müssen wir ausschließen,
weil nach der Elektro-Cardiobation könnte das zu Embolliführen.
Ganz genau, richtig.
Wo gucken Sie da besonders drauf?
Im Ultraschall?
Linker Vorhof.
Auricular.
Linkes.
Orhof.
Or.
Ja, aber latinisch auricular, oder?
Genau.
Ja.
Ich sage nur, damit das, man sagt in Deutschland nicht auricular, sondern
linkes Vorhof.
Alles gut, danke schön.
Okay, noch ein, Sie machen das sehr gut.
Was gibt es in Gründe, was für Gründe gibt es für Vorhof-Limmern?
Ja, es
es könnte primär sein wegen Medikamenter
Annahme, wegen der anatomische
anatomische Situation des Herz, wegen Herzkrankheit.
Ja.
Da müssten wir noch ein bisschen nachgucken, glaube ich.
Es gibt wieder so wahlvolle Vorhof-Limmern.
Alter, alter Geläuter bei alter Geläuter,
ist eigentlich nicht alt, aber ja.
Das stimmt.
Es gibt also wahlvolle Vorhof-Limmern,
nicht wahlvolle Vorhof-Limmern.
Oft haben die ein Metralvizium, der Metralklappe.
Ja.
Manchmal ist es auch ein vergrößertes Vorhof.
Vergrößertes Vorhof.
Er kann auch eine KAK haben.
Ja, mit der klarklarklinne Hose, ja.
Genau, Sie haben eben gesagt, man sollte vielleicht auch eine
Coronangiografie machen.
Das ist richtig.
All die Sachen daran müssten Sie denken.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung, wir haben gar nicht über Blut gesprochen jetzt.
Sie wollten ja auch Blut abnehmen.
Gibt es denn da besondere Werte, die Sie abnehmen möchten?
Ich mache da Blutbildsägen, ob irgendwelche Anämie auszuschließen.
Sehr gut.
Und TSH, Schildloser-Prameter möchte ich auch überprüfen.
Ich mache dafür, also Blutlippid.
Blutlippid-Spieger, oder?
Blutprofil, genau.
Blutprofil auch sägen.
Und dann, ich möchte auch Nierenwerte kontrollieren.
Ich würde mit dem Serpentier anfangen.
Deswegen Nierenwerte, Leberwerte.
Wir können hier auch Proben-Banpe überpuffen.
Ein Wert noch, den habe ich nicht gehört.
Ein Wert.
Haben Sie schon mal von Kalium gehört?
Elektrolyte.
Genau, die müssen Sie mitmachen auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Auch bei, er nimmt ja auch mit der Zappin ein, zum Schlafen.
Da gibt es manchmal Hypronatrimien oder sowas.
Aber insbesondere soll man hier auch an das Kalium denken.
Alles gut.
Ich glaube, der eine Hypokalime hat zum Beispiel.
Warum?
Also muss man mit bedenken.
Und ich habe noch eine Frage.
Und zwar, wenn der Patient selbst zum Beispiel ein paar
oksismales Vorflümmern hat.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Ja, er hat ab und zu Diplomus-Storgen.
Okay.
Muss man ihn dann immer antikorglieren, diesen Patienten?
Ja, das hängt davon ab, wie viel Risiken der Patienten hat für
Embolier.
Also ich messe Chatvastkor.
Sehr gut.
Wenn es mehr als zwei ist, dann fange ich mit dem Antikorglation ein.
Und bei ihm ist es mehr als zwei eigentlich.
Er ist 65 Jahre alt.
Er hat altegelle Hypertonie.
Die zwei.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie würden einen Nord geben.
Ja.
Beispiel?
Wie war Roksa-Bahn?
Warum?
Also ich möchte keinen Marcomar geben.
Das ist er ist ein junger Patient, muss lebenslang diese
Medikamente einnehmen.
Es ist schwieriger, zu kontrollieren, ihren R-Werte stabil
zu halten.
Ich würde dieser Patient mit Nord anfangen, bei dieser
Patient.
Okay.
Gut.
Und wenn Sie den Patienten jetzt wieder in den Rhythmus
bringen möchten.
Wie machen Sie das?
Es gibt verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Und zwar ich könnte Medikamentus behandeln oder elektrische
Kardioversion kommt auch infrage.
Was würden Sie bei den Patienten machen?
Ich würde elektrische Kardioversionen machen.
Warum?
Weil die medikamentöse Therapie viele Nebenwirkungen hat.
Okay.
Ja, wenn die Patient keine, zum Beispiel keine.
Wenn ich schon unauffällig ist, zum Beispiel keine große
Lechterfrau aufhat, dann würde ich erst mal elektrische
Kardioversionen versuchen.
Ja.
Aber vorher müssten Sie eine TEE machen.
Und zu ausschließen irgendwelche Trombos im Herz.
Und jetzt haben Sie eine TEE gemacht und Sie haben ein
Trombus gesehen.
Ja.
Was passiert jetzt?
Wir können keine elektrische Kardioversionen machen,
aber wir haben mit dem NOAC angefangen.
Dann warten wir noch ein bisschen, zum Beispiel ein paar
Wochen, vielleicht drei Wochen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Aber ich würde sagen drei Wochen.
Okay, machen wir vier Wochen.
Okay, vier Wochen.
Nach vier Wochen würde ich noch eine stationäre
Aufnahme planen, dann wieder Trans-Ösofagiale
Eschokardiografie machen und unter aber NOAC Therapie.
Ja.
Frau Bündnis, haben Sie gut gemacht, klasse.
Dankeschön.
Jetzt müssen Sie nur noch den Patienten überreden,
dass er stationär bleibt oder nach Hause geht.
Ja.
Ich würde mit dem Papier von gegen Arsliche Rad
gegen, vielleicht das brauche ich.
Ich würde es sich besser absichern.
Ja.
Muss der Patient denn unterschreiben?
Und wenn er das nicht macht?
Ich rufe dann Polize.
Nein.
Sie müssen das Polizei bringen, nichts.
Sie müssen das selber dokumentieren.
Sie müssen das dokumentieren und am besten
Zeugen haben.
Eine Krankenschwester vielleicht,
eine ärztliche Kollegin, der das mitbezeugen kann.
Ach so, okay.
Das ist richtig.
Weil eigentlich, ich müsste nicht unterschreiben.
Sie können ihn nicht zwingend unterschreiben.
Aber Sie müssen das gut dokumentieren.
Ja.
Ja, klar.
Und weiter so.
Erfolg.
Dankeschön.
Bitte schön.